السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه المتواصله
والحيه والمباشره للصراع المسلح في
السودان والذي يعيش حقبه مظلمه ويجعل
السودانيين امام مفترق طرق
[موسيقى]
عاشروا ايام الحرب بين البرهان وحميتي
تزايد مستمر في اعداد الضحايا والمصابين
تقابله عمليات نزوح من العاصمه الخرطوم
واجلاء للبعثات الدبلوماسيه ورعايا عده
دول في الحصيله الاخيره لضحايا هذا النزاع
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى المدنيين الى 273 فضلا عن تسجيل
نحو 1600 حاله اصابه بين المدنيين منذ
اندلاع الاشتباكات في الخامس عشر من ابريل
الجاري واشارت النقابه الى ان 69% من
المستشفيات متوقفه عن الخدمه حيث انه من
اصل 79 مستشفى في العاصمه 55 مستشفى توقفت
عن الخدمه وحوالي 13 مستشفى تم قصفها
وتسعى عشره مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء القصري
نتيجه للوضع الامني في البلاد
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطورات اجلاء الدول لرعاياها من
السودان نشاهد مشاهدينا هذه الصور لعبور
عدد من شاحنات الاجلاء الى الاراضي
المصريه وتشهد الحدود المصريه السودانيه
استنفارا امنيا وفقا لمراسل العربيه حيث
وصلت دفع جديده من الحافلات لانهاء
الاجراءات لدخول الاراضي المصريه كما افاد
مراسل العربيه ايضا بانه من المنتظر وصول
عدد من حافلات الاجلاء خلال الساعات
القادمه
ومع استمرار القتال في السودان بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع تواصل الحكومه
الفرنسيه عمليات اجلاء رعاياها
ودبلوماسيين من السودان فرنسا كررت دعوتها
لوضع حد للقتال والعوده الى المحادثات
السياسيه بين طرفي الصراع مؤكده انها لا
تزال على اتصال وثيق بشركائها حول تطورات
الوضع في السودان
قبل ذلك وصلت اول طائره للقوات الجويه
الالمانيه الى برلين على متنها اكثر من
100 شخص تم اجلائهم من السودان ليصل عدد
الذين نقلهم الجيش الالماني الى 313 شخصا
حتى الان بحسب ما ذكره مصدر عسكري ونقلت
الطائره وهي من طراز ايربوس
نقلت هؤلاء الاشخاص من قاعده الازرق
الاردنيه التي يستخدمها الجيش الالماني
كمركز لعمليه الاجلاء الى برلين
في سياق ذاته قرر البرلمان السويدي ارسال
400 جندي الى السودان للمساعده في اجلاء
السويديين من هناك حسب ما ذكرت وكاله
الانباء السويديه ورفضت الناطقه باسم
القوات المسلحه السويديه التعليق على موعد
تنفيذ العمليه الا انها اكدت على ان الوضع
الامني في السودان خطير للغايه ويستوجب
المتابعه عن كثب بدوره اكد وزير الدفاع
السويدي جونسون اكد ان القوات المسلحه
عملت بجهد مكثف على هذه القضيه ولديها
مستوى عال من الجاهزيه لاجلاء الرعايه
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل اكد اجلاء بعثه
الكتله الاوروبيه من السودان بامان وداعا
الطرفين المتصارعين على اعلان وقف لاطلاق
النار ولفت بوريل في تغريده على حسابه على
تويتر الى ان سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي يواصل
عمله من السودان مؤكدا ان الاتحاد ملتزم
بالعمل على وقف ومساعده المدنيين
المحاصرين جميعا ويبحث وزراء خارجي الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم الاثنين ازمه
السودان في لوكسمبرج
معنى من لوكسمباغ مراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريضي اهلا بك نور الدين اذا ما الجديد
حول هذه الاجتماعات وهل من تصريحات اخرى
واجراءات اخرى متخذه من الاتحاد الاوروبي
بشان الازمه في السودان نور الدين
صباح الخير فاطمه
مباحثات وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
الازمه السودانيه بدات في غضون اللحظات
بمحاولته تقويم الوضع على الصعيد الامني
والسياسي وخاصه عمليه الاجلاء التي وصفها
جوزيف بوريل بانها كانت عمليه امنه وصعبه
ومعقده في غضون اليومين الماضيين اكثر من
الف من الرعايه الاوروبيه تم اجلائهم
بجهود مشتركه قادتها فرنسا مع المانيا
وهولندا عمليات الاجلاء تمت من شمال ام
درمان من القاعده العسكريه قاعده وادي
سيدنا وهي قاعده عسكريه تحت سيطره القوات
المسلحه السودانيه من هناك اقلعت الطائرات
العسكريه الاوروبيه الفرنسيه وغيرها من
طراز طائرات نقل اي 400 ام من من قاعده
وادي سيدنا في شمال ام درمان نحو
او نحو مناطق اخرى ومن جيبوتي الى مناطق
اخرى او عواسم اخرى مثل عواسم اقليميه مثل
عمان العاصمه الاردنيه
الطاقم الدبلوماسي 21 دبلوماسيا من بعثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي غادروا السودان لكن سفير
او رئيس البعثه الاوروبيه لا يزال في
السودان غاطر غادر الخرطوم مثل ما اجاب
جوزيف بوريل على سؤال العربيه
في اطلاق النار ما الاجراءات تحديدا
المتخذه تجاه ذلك
يعني هاتف في هذه المرحله
لا توجد تفاصيل عن كيفيه الضغط يعني لان
كلاهما يمتلك خزانا كبيرا ومستودعات كبيره
من الاسلحه وقوات كبيره ايضا باعداد كبيره
يعني الجنرال الحمتي قوته تقدر بين 80 الى
120 الف القوات المسلحه السودانيه اعدادها
قد تصل الى 100 الف هناك كميات كبيره من
الاسلحه وبالتالي الضغط الخارجي قد يكون
فقط بوسائل العقوبات التي ربما تطرح على
طاوله الاجتماع في مرحله ما او اليوم او
في الايام المقبله سواء كان هنا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن ربما على سعيد دولي
للتاثير اكثر حده على الجرارين هم كلاهما
ليس في حاجه للدعم العسكري او لاستيراد
الاسلحه ولكن جوزيف بوريل حذر من ان
احتمال يعني تفكك السودان سيؤدي الى موجات
ارتدا
افريقيا بكاملها بمعنى موجات كبيره من
اللاجئين قد تحدث يعني تموج داخل السودان
تهدد المنطقه ككل من غرب افريقيا الى
افريقيا وربما من هناك الى جنوب اوروبا
هناك مخاوف حقيقيه بالنسبه
للجانب الاوروبيين لما قد تؤول له الاوضاع
اذا ما دخل السودان مرحله الحرب الاهليه
وهذا سيناريو ليس مستبعدا لذلك فان
الدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه تدعم ولكن تدعم من
الخلف تترك الدور الريادي الان للاتحاد
الافريقي لمنظمه ايجاد وللامم المتحده
ولكن تدعم مثل ما تدعم اطراف
ذا ثقل كبير مثل مصر
الاثيوبيا ربما يعطي شرعيه لقائد عن اخر
ام يلتزمون الحياد حتى الان
في هذه المرحله لا الموقف الاوروبي لا ليس
منحازا لاي من الطرفين لماذا لان قوات
الدعم السريع هي من الناحيه القانونيه
تعتمر وتخضع لقياده القوات المسلحه التي
يقودها الجنرال البرهان وفي هذه المرحله
موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي حذر جدا وهو الضغط
على جميع الاطراف ولكن مما لا شك فيه ان
معه اذا استمر النزاع فهناك عمليات
تقويم وتقييم سياسي سيقوم بها الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالتشاور مع عواصم المنطقه
وتحديد الجهه المسؤوله ولكن في هذه
المرحله الضغط او المطالبه بالحاح على في
اتجاه الطرفين وقف اطلاق النار من دون
تاخر حتى تتمكن اعمال الاغاثه من استئناف
نشاطاتها وربما لاحقا ربما العمل على
نوعا من الحوار السياسي بين الطرفين او
خاصه المجتمع المدني وهناك يعني
محددات كثيره داخل السودان هناك مجموعات
مسلحه كثيره هناك قوات سياسيه هناك قواس
سياسيه تمتلك اسلحه وبالتالي في هذه
المرحله هناك خوف كبير وبالتالي الضغط
الضغط على طرفي النزاع من اجل وقف اطلاق
النار من دون تاخر شكرا لك من مراسل
العربيه نور الدين الفريضي
نشرت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه صوره لوزير
الخارجيه انتن بلانكن وهو يراقب عمليه
اجلاء الموظفين واسرهم من سفاره واشنطن في
الخرطوم واجلت القوات المسلحه للولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا موظفي سفرتيهما من
السودان بينما سارعت دول اخرى لايصال
مواطنيها الى بر الامان مع اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع في
العاصمه
كما قالت مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه
الدوليه سمانثى باور ان الوكاله نشرت
فريقا من خبراء التعامل مع الكوارث من اجل
تنسيق المساعدات الانسانيه للسودان في ظل
استمرار القتال هناك وقالت باور في بيان
ان الفريق سيعمل من كينيا في المرحله
الاولى واضافت ان الخبراء سيعملون مع
المجتمع الدولي والشركاء لتحديد
الاحتياجات ذات الاولويه وتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه بامان واوضحت مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه ان الولايات المتحده
تحشد الجهود لزياده المساعدات للشعب
السوداني المحاصر بين الجانبين المتحاربين
مذكره بمعاناتهم في ظل نقص الامدادات
الغذائيه والادويه وانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في سياق اخر شددت باور على ان
هذا القتال الذي يدور حاليا بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تسبب في حصد
ارواح المئات وقضى مره اخرى على التطلعات
الديمقراطيه للشعب السوداني حسب قولها ثم
جددت دعوتها للجانبين المتحاربين للالتزام
بهدنه من اجل تسهيل وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه للسودان في امان ومن دون عوائق
ينضم الينا الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
الشفيع محمد احمد اهلا بك سيد احمد
يعني تقول باور بان الامال السودانيين
بتحول الديمقراطي قد انتهت هل صحيح هذا
الكلام
طيب في البدء دعني عبر شاشتكم الموقره ان
قلت تهنئه للامه العربيه والاسلاميه بعيد
الفطر المبارك اعاده الله علينا وعليكم
وعلى الامه العربيه والاسلاميه بالخير
واليمن والبركات عطفا على سؤالك ان الواقع
الان بكل تعقيداته وبكل تشابكاته لا يمكن
باي حال من الاحوال ان يكون المقابل لهذه
الحرب التخلي عن المسار الديموغرافي هذه
المعركه الدائره الان ليست معركه الشعب
السوداني وليست معركه الدوله السودانيه
هذه معركه دائره ما بين شخصين تحركهم
اهدافهم وطموحاتهم الشخصيه في الحكم وفي
النفوذ معركه الشعب السوداني معركه واضحه
منذ ثوره ديسمبر المجيده او دعنا نكون
اكثر دقه منذ بدايه المشروع الثوري في
2018 معركه الدوله السودانيه هي دوله
العداله دوله القانون دوله الكرامه
الانسانيه دوله تقف على مسافه متساويه من
الجميع الان نحن معركه عربيه
المقاطعه ولكن وليست معركه الشعب
على الشاشه من الخارجيه البولنديه التي
تعلن اجلاء سفيرها في السودان وعشره
مواطنين طيب تفضل السيد احمد لتكمل الفكره
معاركه الشعب السوداني معروفه وواضحه
المعالم وينبغي ان تصل الى مالاتها
النهائيه نحن الان امام حرب فرضت علينا
كقوه ثوره حيه وقوه تنشد الديمقراطيه تنشد
العداله تنشد المساواه تنشد بناء دوله
حقيقيه تكون لكل الدوله لكل مواطني
المواطنين السودانيين حالما انجلت هذه
الحرب نحن سنواصل في مشروعنا نحو الدوله
الديمقراطيه ونحو المدنيه ونحو العداله
على الله المتاحه امام السودان لاجلاء هذه
الازمه كما ذكرت
واختي الفاضله هذه معركه زيرو صم هذه
معركه عسكريه وليست معركه سياسيه ليس من
الممكن ولا المعقول الحديث عن تسويه
سياسيه في سياق الازمه السودانيه الحاليه
هذه معركه وصلت وصفه الحقيقه انها معركه
اللعوده ما بين الجرارين هذه المعركه
تنتهي بانتصار احد على الاخر انا من حيث
المبدا
ضد الحرب وضد البربريه وضد الظلم وضد
الضحايا وضد الابرياء وضد المدنيين لكن
ارى ان هذه الحربه حتميه لانه كان هنالك
وضع شرعي في الدوله السودانيه احد افرازات
فشلت الدوله السودانيه منذ عام 1956
الدرور في شكل دوله لا يمكن ان يكون هنالك
جيشين في دوله في كل دول العالم الان ليس
هنالك وضع شبيه بوضع الدوله السودانيه
طيب سيد احمد يعني كما ذكرت وذكر ايضا بعض
المراقبين ذلك بان هذه الحرب حتميه ولابد
منها لتنتقل السودان الى مرحله افضل مما
كانت عليه ولكن ما ان تدخلت دول خارجيه
واطراف خارجيه يعني في حال طال النزاع
يعني سيكون هناك فرصه اكبر لاطراف خارجيه
بان يعني تتحيز لهذا الطرف او ذاك وتحاول
يعني تجنيد هذا الطرف لصالحها ومصالحها
والاستفاده واستغلال ثروات السودان لصالح
دول واطراف معينه
وانا في الحقيقه متخوف من شيئين الشيء
الاول هو ما ذكرتيه انت بالتحديد ما اكثر
الضرر كسره الايادي في الطبخ السودانيه
وكل يغني على ليلاه وكل يبحث عن مصالحه
واطمعه وكل تحركه اطماعه
اما اذا نظرنا الى الموضوع التخوف التاني
التخوف منها يتحور الصراع الى صراع اسمي
قبائلي او مناطقي او تتحول الى حرب اهليه
نحن نامل ان ينحصر الصراع في شكله الان
ولا ياخذ اي ابعاد اخرى يمكن ان تقود
السودان الى المجهول والدوله السودانيه
دوله مازومه مازومه منذ عام 1956 لا توجد
لا توجد دوله الان نحن نتحدث عن الدوله لا
توجد دوله في السودان الان في غياب تام
للدوله الازمه هذه هي القطر التي طفع لها
الكيل لكن المتابع للمشهد السياسي منذ
2019 الى الان في حاله غياب تام للدوله
حاله غياب تام للمؤسسات الدوله السودانيه
الان في اضعف حلقاتها
الباب مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات لكن يعني
نفعه جاهدين بعمل داؤوب وعمل جاك في ان لا
تنفلط الامور عن السيطره وان لا تنهار
وتتشتت الدوله السودانيه طيب لكن
لا حل سياسي لهذه الازمه حاليا يعني هل
فقط هو حل عسكري ام يمكن لبعض الدول
الخارجيه ان يعني تلعب دور الوسيط بين
الطرفين العسكريين لوجود حل هذه الازمه
ومن برايك يمكن التدخل لحل حالات هذه
الازمه او على الاقل اطلاق وقف اطلاق
النار
الشاهد الان من الواضح انهما ليس هنالك
امكانيه وليس هنالك استعداد لاي من رجلين
للجلوس لحوار هؤلاء
الطائعان في السلطه سيذهبان في الحرب الى
نهاياتها هذه الحرب ستنتهي بخروج احد
الرجلين من المشهد نهائيا ثم من ينتصر في
هذا الحرب عليه ان يواجه الشعب السوداني
وعليه ان يواجه المشروع السوري السوداني
المتمسك باهدافه والتي قدم الغالي والنفيس
من اجلها
طيب سيد احمد يعني حتى كل الدول
انا متابع على مدار الساعه كل المؤشرات
تقول ان الجيش السوداني عازم للقضاء على
هذه المليشه صحيح هنالك ضحايا صحيح هنالك
ابرياء لكن هذه معركه لا بد منها
ان لا ارى في الافق الان امكانيه لاي
تسويه سياسيه او لاي وقف اطلاق النار وتري
مؤشرات هذا الشيء من خلال اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب عمليات الاجلاء المكثفه هذه هذه
الهدنه الان 72 ساعه الهدنه
فرضت على الطرفين لاجلها شيء واحد هواء
الرعايه الاجانب
هذا مؤشر واضح على ان هذه الحرب لن تتوقف
هذه الحرب تتوقف بانتصار احد الطرفين وانا
حيث المبدا لست دائما لاي من الطرفين لكن
لا اقبل منطقيا ان تنتصر ميليشيا على جيش
وطني على سوءاته ويظل في مؤسسه مؤسسات
الدوله السودانيه عند اخفاءاتها ككثير من
مؤسسات الدوله السودانيه
ابقى معي كرما
[موسيقى]
يوجد فيها احداث معارك حقيقيه الرصاص كان
ياتي من فوق رؤوسنا دائما
كنا كثيرا يعني لا نستطيع ان نرجع الى
بيوتنا نضطر الى ان نجلس عند اخرين
انه الينا من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني حموره زياده اهلا بك سيد زياده
يعني في ظل اجلاء المواطنين الاجانب من
السودان يعني جميع الدول تقوم بعمليات
الاجلاء ان كان دول عربيه او حتى اوروبيه
بالاضافه الى الولايات المتحده وفي ظل
الصراع الدائره الان داخل الخرطوم
والسودان بشكل عام ما تقييمك للوضع هناك
اليوم يبدو ان هناك هدوء حذر رغم انقطاع
شبكه الاتصالات وخدمه الانترنت لكن
الاخبار الوارده تقول ان الاشتباكات هي
اشتباكات قليله في اماكن متفرقه
ربما لاول يوم يغيب الطيران من التحليق في
سماء الخرطوم وبالتالي لا تسمع الدويه
انفجارات ولا صواريخ المضاده
للطائرات لكن يعني دعينا نتذكر اننا في
نهايه مهله 72 ساعه
هذا اليوم هذا اللي هو اليوم الاخير عند
الساعه السادسه مساء ستنتهي الهدنه المؤسف
ان في اليومين السابقين لم يكن للهدنه اي
وجود الا لوقت قليل جدا تم فيه اجلاء
موظفي السفاره الفرنسيه
الامريكيه
وللاسف لم يكن بقيه طواقم السفارات بنفس
امس هو اول امس ففي البارحه تم الاعتداء
على موكب اجلاء السفاره الفرنسيه لكن
اليوم استطاعوا تقريبا الخروج بامان هناك
ايضا صفار القطريه تعرض حمله اجلائها
لاعتداءات هذا يقودنا ان هذه المهله في
الايام السابقه لم يعني يلتزم بها الطرفان
الالتزام في هذا اليوم ربما يكون هو
لاعاده ترتيب قواتهم من
اشتباك ومعركه داميه قادمه بعد انتهاء
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب واعطاء فرصه
اضطراريه للمواطنين بتوفيق اوضاعهم قليلا
خاصه مع حركه النزوح الكبيره
المغادره الى مصر وغيرها من الدول
فقد تكون هذه ليله نقول احنا على اعتاب
ليله جديده من الاشتباكات ما لم يجد نجاح
محاولات الوساطه تم اجلائهم ولكن ماذا عن
المواطنين السودانيين في المناطق المتضرره
والتي يقام فيها الحرب والصراعات
والاشتباكات ما الخيارات المتاحه امامهم
للخروج من هذه المناطق هل النزوح هو الحل
هل هناك خيرات امامهم للخروج خارج حتى
الدوله في ظل الضرب وتضرر المطارات حتى
هو طبعا مطار الخرطوم مغلق من اليوم الاول
بعد الاشتباك فيه وتم تدمير جوانب منه
ايضا المجال الجوي هو مغلق فلا وسيله
لمغادره الخرطوم جوا الوسيله الوحيده هي
عن طريق البر
الخروج من السودان بريا الى مصر هو خيار
اسهل لسكان الخرطوم او النزوح من الخرطوم
الى مدن اقليميه وولائيه اخرى داخل
السودان لم تطلها الحرب ولا توجد فيها
اشتباكات هناك ربما يكون المواطنون في
امان من القتال لكن بالتاكيد ستكون هناك
مشاكل اخرى انهم ليس لديهم اماكن ليسكنوا
فيها المواد الغذائيه الموجوده في كثير من
المناطق هي بتعتمد على الخرطوم
الان ستحدث ندره في المواد الغذائيه وفي
وايضا في الامداد الكهربائي وفي امداد
المياه كما حدث في الخرطوم فخروج
المواطنين من الخرطوم حتى هذه اللحظه قد
يبدو امنا لكن اذا لم تتوقف هذه الحرب
باسرع وقت فان المعاناه الانسانيه ستنتقل
الى بقيه المدن حتى اذا لم تنتقل اليها
الرصاص طيب بالحديث عن المعاناه الانسانيه
والوضع الانساني سيد زياده يعني كيف هو
الان في ظل المستشفيات القليله والباقي
المتضرر والوضع الجثث في الشوارع وايضا
المصابين كيف هو الوضع الانساني في
السودان في ظل هذه الهدنه التي ستنتهي
قريبا
الوضع الانساني سيء جدا وينذر بكارثه
وكذلك الوضع الامني انا في الوضع العمليات
العسكريه انما فيلات الامن الذي له من
الشواهد ان والي ولايه الخرطوم التي هي
العاصمه يخرج واليها ويطالب من لجان
الاحياء ان تحمي اماكن سكنها من النهب ومن
التفلتات هذا يعني غياب الدوله غياب
الشرطه ان الجيش لا يستطيع ان يحمي
المواطنين للاسف هذه كارثه كبيره جدا مع
خروج كثير جدا من المستشفيات من الخدمه
المستشفيات العامله من الصعب الوصول اليها
المستشفيات العامله لا يوجد بها طواقم
طبيه كافيه تم تدمير مخزن الامدادات
الطبيه مما ينذر بازمه دواء حاده
الامداد الكهربائي والامداد المائي به
مشاكل تحسن قليلا من الايام الثلاثه
الاولى ولكن ما زال يعاني من مشاكل انقطاع
شبكه الانترنت وشبكه الاتصالات على ما
يبدو انه لم يكن بقرار حكومي انما نتيجه
لتضرر هذه الشركات من القصف والحرب هذا
الوضع الانساني لا يقودنا الا الى الوقوف
مع الجبهه التي ترفع شعار لا للحرب التي
تطالب بوقف اطلاق النار فورا لان اي يوم
تستمر فيه هذه المعركه تحت توهمات الطرفين
ان اليوم القادم هو يوم الحسم وان اليوم
القادم هو يوم الانتصار ثبت لنا في خلال
عشره ايام ان هذا اليوم لا ياتي وان هذا
اليوم ياتي يعني ياتي قبله دائما خسائر
متزايده فكل يوم لهذه الحرب يعني مزيد من
المعاناه ربما الامل الان على الجبهه
الداخليه التي بدات في تشكيل
موقف ضد هذه الحرب هناك وقفات احتجاجيه
هناك
نعم نعم انا اتحدث عن ثلاث قطاعات الان
بالترتيب في البدايه هم المواطنون
السودانيون
موقف رفع هذه الوقات الاحتجاجيه والمواكب
الرافضه للحرب في بعض المناطق الامنه ثم
هناك موقف الاحزاب السياسيه والشخصيات
العامه التي رفعت مذكرات هناك عده مبادرات
للتوقيع على مذكرات من اجل وقف الحرب
وهناك الجهه الاخيره طبعا هي المجتمع
الدولي والحلفاء الاقليميون
للمتصارعين اعتقد ان التكاتف المواقف ما
بين القطاعات والجهات الثلاث هذه يمكن ان
يؤدي الى وقف سريع لاطلاق النار اذا اراد
الجنرالين ان يحتكما الى صوت العقل لان
وقف معاناه المواطنين هي القضيه الاهم لا
يمكن القبول بحرب
تحت اي ادعاء وقبول مثل هذه الخسائر
باعتبارها خسائر مقبوله او خسائر
هذه الحرب في اقرب وقت ممكن ابقى معي
السيد حمور الزياده
نعيد التذكير بالاتهامات المتبادله بين
قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو
والمعروف بحميدتي فخلال لقائهما غير
المباشر عبر العربيه اتهم كل طرف اخر ببدء
الحرب وخرق الهدنه والهجوم على منازل
السكان والبعثات الاجنبيه لنتابع
البرهان وحميدتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحماتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
احنا كنا موجودين في مقراتنا وتم الهجوم
علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
[موسيقى]
من اجل وسط الاحياء السكنيه فقط
المهندسين
اين يوجد البرهان وحميتي
من اخرج الا محمولا على نعش
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في
الهدنه حتى ابتدعت لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الاحياء
السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام
علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع
البرهان
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
اخرجت المواطنين في المنازل اخرجت
المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
لم تعلق
الى هذه الحرب
هل هذه الحرب ليس فيها كاسد
نعود الى اوستن وضيفي من هناك الاكاديمي
والباحث السياسي الشفيعه محمد احمد سيد
احمد يعني كنا نتحدث قبل قليل بان لا حل
سياسي في السودان مع الاوضاع الراهنه ولكن
برايي كما ان تم حسم هذه المعركه كيف
سيكون مستقبل السودان السياسي
وفي الواقع لابد يعني ان تنتهي هذه الحرب
مستقبل السودان السياسي يحدد السودانيين
الشرفاء وليس العملاء مستقبل السودان
السياسي
يحدده هذا الشباب السائر من اجل مشروع
وطني سوداني حقيقي مشروع الثوره السودانيه
سوف يستمر سوف ينتصر في حاله عدم انتصار
المشروع الثوري السوداني هذا يعني غياب
الدوله السودانيه وانهيار وتفكك الدوله
السودانيه مستقبل الدوله السودانيه لا يجب
ان يحدده الشرفاء اصحاب المبادئ اصحاب
المشاريع الوطنيه الواقع ان الدوله
السودانيه الان على مر تاريخها منذ عام
1956 الان لم تتعرض الى محاك حقيقي الان
الدوله السودانيه امام محاك حقيقي من اجل
تحديد اي دوله يريدها السودانيين
السودانيين يريدون دوله تعبر عنهم جميعا
يريدون دوله
تحترم المواطن دوله تراها الحقوق
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه للشعب
السوداني دوله
دوله
الاطراف سيقدم ذلك للسودان برايك كيف سيتم
تقديم ذلك للسودان وتلبيه مطالبهم
يتم يتم ذلك عبر العمل السياسي جات
المشروع الثوري لابد ان يستمر الثوره لابد
ان تستمر الان نحن ندعو الثوار الى
استراحه محارب حاله انقشاء هذه الازمه سوف
سوف تعود الشوارع تحتف من اجل الثوره ومن
اجل الدوله المدنيه ونقل الدوله
الديمقراطيه وهذه حتميات لابد المشروع هذا
لا بد ان ينجح هذا قليل الصحفي حمور زياده
ذكر سيد احمد بان تكاتف جهات معينه مثل
المواطنين السودانيين والجهات الدوليه او
المجلس الامن كذلك يعني تكاتف هذه الجهات
مع الشعب السوداني ومطالب السودانيين يمكن
ان يقدم يعني بصيص امل للشعب السوداني هل
برايك وقفه المواطنين امام هذا الصراع
يمكن ان يؤدي الى انهائه
انه هذا الصراع الان الدائر لا توجد في
الافق اي امكانيه لحلية هذا الصراع يحل
عسكريا
ونحن نبحث عن دوله المؤسسات من اهم
اساسيات دوله المؤسسات التي ننشدها ان
هناك مؤسسه عسكريه واحده جيش وطني واحد
ايا كانت التسويه اذا اذا غدر وتم التسويه
لابد ان تتم وفق بناء منهجي ومؤسسي للدوله
السودانيه طيب ولكن سؤالي السيد احمد ما
ان وقف او اتحد المواطن السوداني معا
ووقفوا ضد هذه الاشتباكات هل يمكن ان يكون
لهم تاثير مباشر على وقفها
والله في الافق المنظور لا يوجد يعني
تاثير حقيقي على الارض لا حتى على الداخل
ولا حتى الضغوطات الخارجيه لم تاتي اكلها
من الواضح ان هذه الحرب سوف تنتهي بخروج
احد الطرفين من المشهد نهائيا الوقفات
السودانيه مقدره تحالف اوقف الحرب لا
للحرب مغدر لكن ليس هنالك مردود حقيقي
الحرب مستمره والحرب هتستمر هذه الحرب سوف
تنتهي بخروج احد الطرفين على المشهد
نهائيا
كل المجهودات الوطنيه لوقف الحرب لكن
الشاهد الواقع المماثل امامنا في تحليلاته
العميقه بتقول على انه ليس هنالك افق في
المدى المنظور لوقف هذه الحرف لكن دعني
اؤكد على نقطه مهمه ان مستقبل الدوله
السودانيه
يجب ان يحدده السودانيين ان مستقبل الدوله
السودانيه المنشوده يجب ان يحدده
السودانيين وتقع مسؤوليته على السودانيين
فقط نرحب بالاشقاء ونرحب بالمجتمع الدولي
في مساعدتنا لكن القضيه برمتها قضيه الشعب
السوداني ان يجب على الشعب السوداني ان
يحدد اي دوله يريد طيب في ظل هذه الهدنه
سيد احمد التي شهدناها والتي هي على مشارف
الانتهاء كما نعلم لماذا لم يتم فتح اي
ممرات انسانيه ادخال اي مساعدات انسانيه
للسودان واستغلال هذه الفتره الهادئه
هو يا عزيزتي الفاضله الواقع على درجه
عاليه من التعقيد انت امام الوضع الان في
الخرطوم وضع على درجه ماساوي كارثه الهدنه
هذه ظاهرها وهدفها الوحيد هو لعمليه اغلاء
الرعايه الاجانب ليس
كمؤشر
لمعنيه
بالشعب السوداني حتى السودانيون حملت
الجوازات الاجنبيه لم يستطيعوا ان يتم
اجلاهم منعم يتيم مجلاهم عبر تصريح مشهور
لوزاره الخارجيه السودانيه انها لم تسمح
باجلاء السودانيين حمله الجوازات الاجنبيه
الهدنه هذه الغرض منها شيء واحد واضح لك
انت واضح للمتابع الغرض منها هو اغلاق
الرعايه الاجانب والدبلوماسيه الاجانب لكن
لا تعني اطراف الصراع ولا تعني ضحايا
الضحايا الحرب السودانيين واضح شكرا جزيلا
لك من اوستن عاصمه تكساس الاكاديمي
والباحث السياسي الشفيع محمد احمد
اصبحت مدينه الابيض الان امنه سالمه هانئه
مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح الاسواق
ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمينه طلبت منظمه
الصحه العالميه بعدم استهداف المرافق
الصحيه والعاملين والمرضى في السودان
بعدما وثقت المنظمه عده هجمات مميته
استهدفت المؤسسات الصحيه ويعاني القطاع
الطبي في السودان من اوضاع صعبه زادها
النزاع الدائر حاليا سوءا
كما العاده في كل النزاعات والصراعات
المدنيون هم الضحيه الاكبر لها وهذا وضع
السودان اليوم جثث ملقاه في الشوارع وما
من جهه تتمكن من نقلها لمثواها الاخير مع
تضارب الاحصاءات حول عدد القتلى بين
الجهات المحليه والدوليه فترات هدنه
المتقطعه لم توفر ممرات امنه لتخفيف وطئه
النزاع وتاثيرها على المواطن السوداني
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد
مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين
من ابريل الجاري بحسب التقرير سجلت
الخرطوم اعلى عدد من القتلى ب122 ثلاث
ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين قتيلا ثم
ولايه شمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا في
عدد المرشح للزياده المعوقات المحنه
بنواجهك هلال احمد سوداني تواجهها كل
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله في السودان
اللي ابرزه عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه من جانبها اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء ان 72% من المستشفيات القريبه من
مناطق الاشتباك توقفت عن الخدمه من اصل 79
مستشفى اساسيا في العاصمه والولايات من
المجموع الكلي للمستشفيات بقي اثنتان
وعشرون مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او جزئي
لكنها تبقى مهدده بالاغلاق نتيجه نقص
الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه وانقطاع الماء
والكهرباء كما ان عده مناطق يكثر فيها
الجرحى لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه الوصول
اليها بيان نقابه الاطباء اضاف ان اربعه
مستشفيات في مدينه الاوبيض تعرضت للقصف ما
يرفع العدد الكلي للمستشفيات التي قصفت
الى 13 مستشفى
اليها تسعه عشر مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري كما تعرضت ست مركبات اسعاف
للاعتداء من قبل قوات عسكريه بينما لم يتم
السماح لعدد من سيارات الاسعاف بالمرور
لنقل المرضى وايصال المعونات حسب ما قالت
نقابه اطباء السودان من جانبه طالب الهلال
الاحمر بتحييد المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات
القتاليه لتجنب الانهيار الكامل للقطاع
الصحي في السودان حسن جوليد العربيه
نشير الى هذه العواجل التي تردنا اتباعا
على الشاشه امامنا مشاهدين حيث يقول الدعم
السريع بانهم يوصلون تامين عمليات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب وتسهيل عبور المواطنين
لمناطق امنه وبانهم يعملون على تامين
مصادر الخدمات الضروريه وليسوا المسؤولين
عن انقطاعها وذكر الدعم السريع كذلك بان
هناك خطه مشبوهه بتنفيذ عمليه سلب ونهب
والصاق التهمه بعناصرها نعود الى القاهره
وضيفي من هناك الكتبي الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني حمور زياده سيد زياده يعني
تحدثنا قبل قليل عن الوضع الانساني
الماساوي في السودان اثر هذه الاشتباكات
والمستشفيات المكتظه المستشفيات العاطله
عن العمل ولكنك ذكرت نقطه لافته بان ثلاث
جهات ما ان تكاتفت يمكن حللت هذه الازمه
ولكن يختلف معك ضيفي من تكساس حيث قال بان
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك اي حل للازمه في
السودان الا عسكريا ما تع ليقك
اعتقد ان الرهان على الحراك السلمي
والجهود السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
عاده ما يكون هو الرهان الافضل بالتاكيد
هذه جهود لا يمكن لاحد ان يضمن نتيجتها
لكن هي محاولات لا بد من دعمها لان
الاعتراف والاقرار بان هذه المعركه لا
يمكن ان تنتهي الا عسكريا يعني ببساطه
قبول استمرار المعاناه يعني ببساطه
استمرار الموت استمرارا النزوح
فلا يعني لا يمكن
لاي شخص او اي جهه ان تقف على الرصيف
متفرجه تنتظر نهايه المعارك ثم بعد ذلك
ننتقل الى مرحله المعركه السياسيه مع
المنتصر من اجل دوله مدنيه وديمقراطيه لا
توجد دوله ديمقراطيه مدنيه يمكن ان
ما بين البنادق
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلي يحاول
ان يكتسب شرعيه وان يحشد المواطنين في
صففه
داعما انه يمكن ان ياتي الينا بالدوله
الديمقراطيه على ظهر سيارات الدفع الرباعي
وهذا امر مستحيل
بقواعد زياده بكسب شرعيه هل يقومون بذلك
ايضا عندما صرحوا بانهم يواصلون تامين
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وتسهيل عبور
المواطنين لمناطق امنه يعني تسهيلهم
لاجلاء الاجانب هل هذه تعطيهم شرعيه
ساعود الى هذه النقطه فقط يعني اريد ان
اكمل انه الجهات الثلاثه التي تحدثت عنها
المواطنين والجهات السياسيه ثم المجتمع
الدولي جزء من عملهم في الضغط على هذه
العمليات الحربيه وايقافها ومساله سحب
الشرعيه من الطرفين الشرعيه العسكريه يعني
ان هذه الحرب لا مشروعيه لها وهذه حرب
مجنونه يجب ان تقف نعود الى محاولات الدعم
السريعه هذه تظهر ان الدعم السريع تماما
كما القوات المسلحه التي تحاول عبر
اعلامها وتوجيها المعنوي ان تقدم سرديتها
الخاصه كل طرف يحاول ان يكسب ما يفعله
مشروعيه الخطير فيما يفعله الدعم السريع
الان في تقديري ان الدعم السريع له حوالي
ثلاثه ايام او اربعه ايام يحاول ان يقدم
نفسه
كدوله موازيه هو تحرك من قوه ثوريه التي
يريد كان ان يقدم بها نفسه انه يقاتل من
اجل الديمقراطيه وهذا طبعا في تقديري غير
صحيح لكنه الان انتقل الى نقطه انه حكومه
ودوله موازيه انه يدعي انه ساعد على اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب
وموظفي السفارات اعلن انه سيساعد على عوده
الخدمات وسيؤمن مقدمي الخدمات ومقدمي
الاعانات الصحيه كي يمارسوا عملهم هنا هنا
لا يتحدثون عن وقف اطلاق نار او مسارات
امنه انما يتحدث كسلطه ستفرض نفسها على
الواقع وتمكن الموظفين من العمل تحت
حمايتهم هذا واقع خطير جدا لانه سيؤدي الى
انقسام يعني على الاقل انقسام جغرافي كان
الدعم السريع قبل ايام ايضا قد اعلن عن
ارقام طوارئ للاتصال به
المواطنين في حاله حوجتهم الى اي مساعده
في المناطق التي سماها مناطق سيطرته هذا
اسم مزعج جدا ومقلق ان يطلق على العاصمه
ان تكون العاصمه مجزئه ما بين سلطتين وان
يضطر المواطنون الى اللجوء الى المواطنين
زياده اماكن الدول التي يعني تتواصل مع
الدعم السريع لتسهيل الاجراء واخراج
مواطنيهم ايضا تعطي
مزيد من الفجوه في هذا الصراع والاشتباكات
اليس كذلك
وطبعا يعني تواصل الدول مع الدعم السريع
قد يبدو مفهوما ويكون دائما بشكل سري
عندما تكون على الارض لديك مواطنون
وموظفون عالقون بين قوتين مسلحهتين فانت
لا يمكن ان تجليهم باتفاق مع جهه واحده
حتى لو كنت تعتبريها الجهه الشرعيه لكن
انت تتواصلي مع الجهتين في تقديري انما ما
راجع امس من تصريحات للدعم السريع انه نسق
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من اجل
اجلاء موظفي سفارتها هذا منطقيا قد يكون
سليم لكن بالتاكيد لا يمكن ان تعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن ذلك لذلك
اعلان الدعم السريع ايضا يدل على نقص في
الخبره هو في سعيه المحموم لاكتساب شرعيه
يريد ان يهلل بانه نسق مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبذلك هو يحرج الاداره
الامريكيه واصر على هذا الاحراج مره اخرى
عندما قال المستشار السياسي لقائد الدعم
السريع ان الاداره الامريكيه نفت التنسيق
معنا لانها تخشى احراجها امام الكونجرس
وبذلك اكد واعاد الاحراج مره اخرى مما
سيجعل اي جهه تريد التنسيق مره اخرى مع
الدعم السريع في حرج بالغ ان هذه جهه غير
مسؤوله لا تقدر الاتصالات السريه ولا تعلم
ضرورات التي يمكن ان تفعلها الدول من اجل
ادلاء رعاياها طيب سيد زياده يعني الجيش
استطاع ان يحسم المعركه في مروي في الابيض
كما شاهدنا قبل قليل في الفيديو الذي
عرضناه ويطالبون سكان الابيض بان يمارسون
حياتهم الطبيعيه ويفتحون محلاتهم ويبداون
تجارتهم ما الذي يعطيه الامد الحرب في
الخرطوم برايك
ومن الواضح ان قوات الدعم السريع بعد
الخسائر البشريه الكبيره التي تكبدتها في
الخرطوم انها اضطرت الى ان تسحب قواتها من
بقيه السودان او من عدد دول ولايات كثيره
من ولايات السودان لا استطيع ان ازعم انهم
انسحبوا من كل الاماكن لكنه من سحبوا من
اماكن كثيره واضح ان معركه الخرطوم
بالنسبه للطرفين هي المعركه الرئيسيه خاصه
يعني اذا تذكرنا ان السودان دوله مركزيه
جدا الخدمات كلها في الخرطوم السلطه كلها
في الخرطوم
يعني الكثير من المواد الغذائيه التي سواء
تصنع محليا او تاتي مستورده من الخارج هي
تنتقل الى الولايات عبر الخرطوم
فالسيطره على الخرطوم بالتالي تعطي سيطره
مباشره على بقيه المدن انا في تقديري ان
قوات الدعم السريع تماما مثل القوات
المسلحه
الهدنه القصيره هذه من اجل حشد قواتها
واعاده التمركز لكن الدعم السريع ربما
يكون يحاول ان يحشد قواته من خارج السودان
ايضا سواء قوات التي ارسلها او عمليات
تجنيد لان هناك اتهامات يعني لا يمكن
التحقق منها لكن هي ايضا لا يمكن تكذيبها
بشكل قاطع ان الدعم السريع يقوم بتجنيد في
بعض المناطق في دول مجاوره اعتقد انه
يحتاج الى الامداد لانه اذا كان لديه كميه
من السلاح لكنه ايضا يحتاج الى المقاتلين
لذلك اعتقد ان هناك احتشاد لمعركه قادمه
في الخرطوم
الدعم السريع حتى هذه اللحظه حسب يعني
شهادات من نعرف بشكل شخصي يسيطر على اماكن
كثيره جدا في الارض ويحاول ان اتصرف
كحكومه يقيم ارتكازات عسكريه وامنيه في
الشوارع يتحقق من بطاقات المواطنين حتى
يعتقل اي شخص تابع للقوات المسلحه لكن هذا
امر لا يمكن ان يستمر لانه في اي لحظه
عندما تنتهي الهدنه سيعود الطيران مره
اخرى للقصف وستعود الاجتماعي شكرا جزيلا
لك من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي السوداني
حمور زياده
الناس كلها كلها سكان هنا بتاع البحريه
يعني شبه كلها سكان يعني المشكله بتاعت
المويه ثمانيه ايام بالليله
يعني انا ماء تماما ولا يوجد عندنا كهرباء
كنا في
[موسيقى]
السكر
ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تغطيتنا الحيه للاحداث في السودان مستمره
لكن نتوقف مع بعض الاخبار من ملفات اخرى
اعلن وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي عن اجتماع
لوزراء دفاع ورؤساء استخبارات تركيا
وروسيا سوريا وايران غدا الثلاثاء في
موسكو حيث سيتم تخصيص الاجتماع لاعاده
بناء العلاقات بين تركيا وسوريا وبحث على
التطورات في الشمال السوري وذلك بحسب
وكاله الاناضول هذا واستضافت روسيا
اجتماعا لوزيري الدفاع السوري والتركي في
ديسمبر من العام الماضي لتشمل ايران التي
ايدت التقارب بين الاطراف الثلاثه
يعقد مجلس الامن اليوم جلسه مفتوحه على
المستوى الوزاري يتراسها وزير خارجيه
روسيا
التي تتراس باول الذي يتراس بلاده المجلس
للشهر الحالي وستشهد الجلسه مناقشه تعدديه
فعاله عبر الدفاع عن مبادئ ميثاق الامم
المتحده كما يتراس رافلوب ايضا جلسه
مناقشات حول الشرق الاوسط غدا وكان وزير
الخارجيه الروسي اشار الى ان الحقيقه التي
ستطرحها بلاده من منبر مجلس الامن ستكون
اكثر اهميه من المعلومات الغربيه
المزعومه ضد موسكو على حد قوله
اعلن حاكم مدينه سيفاستوبول بشبه جزيره
القرم ان قوات اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
دمرت مسيره مائيه واحده في محيط مدينه
يافا ستوبول وانفجرت اخرى من تلقاء نفسها
نشرا الى عدم وقوع ايه اضرار تجدر الاشاره
الى ان سيفاستوبول هي القاعده الرئيسيه
لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي وفي الاشهر
الاخيره جرت عده محاولات لمهاجمتها
بمسيارات جويه ومائيه
كشفت دراسه قام بها باحثون في مجال الامن
في معهد ستوكهولمان معدل الانفاق العسكري
في اوروبا ارتفع بوتيره سريعه وغير مسبوقه
واشارت الدراسه الى ان اوروبا عززت
انفاقها على جيوشها عام 2022
بنسبه 13% مقارنه بالاشهر السابقه وتحديدا
بعد الحرب على اوكرانيا حيث تم تسجيل رقم
قياسي للمره الثامنه على التوالي بمعدل
اثنين فاصله 24 ترليون دولار وهو مستوى لم
تشهده القاره منذ الحرب البارده وفق ما
افادت به الدراسه
يتوجه رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه الى واشنطن في
زياره تستغرق سته ايام حيث يعزز الحلفاء
التعاون العسكري بشان برنامج الاسلحه
النوويه الموسع لكوريا الشماليه كما سيبحث
الطرفان سبوله عزيزي العلاقه بين البلدين
وايضا مناقشه التطورات الحاصله بخصوص
كوريا الشماليه والحرب على اوكرانيا
نكمل معكم تغطيه احداث السودان مع الزميل
احمد الهادي على راس الساعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات